[Música]
francia exigirá el pase de vacunación
además vuelve al teletrabajo y se limita
la cantidad de personas en reuniones
estas son algunas de las medidas con las
que el gobierno espera reducir la
incidencia de nuevos contagios
tenemos análisis en esta emisión
la asamblea nacional de venezuela el
tribunal supremo cercano al oficialismo
declaró en desacato prolongó la
presidencia interina de juan guaidó un
año más pero no todos los opositores
respaldan la medida
el funeral del nobel de paz y líder del
movimiento contra el apartheid
sudafricano desmond tutu se realizará el
primero de enero hasta el día previo y
como homenaje las campanas en ciudad del
cabo sonaran a diario
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
saludarlos y comenzamos hablando de
francia porque este país endurece sus
medidas ante el aumento de contagios de
kobe 19 el gobierno aprobó el proyecto
de ley para exigir la prueba de
vacunación que se necesitará para entrar
a restaurantes cines y transportes de
larga distancia si esto lo aprueba la
asamblea nacional el pase de vacuna
funcionaría a partir del 15 de enero y
ya una prueba pcr no sería suficiente
además para frenar la incidencia de
nuevos contagios que está en su nivel
más alto desde el inicio de la pandemia
ahora sólo podrá haber 2.000 personas en
eventos de espacios cerrados y la
mascarilla será obligatoria en los
centros urbanos
para profundizar esta información
conectamos a esta hora con philip
volante él es analista político
internacional y representante en bogotá
del partido francés la república en
marcha señor volante como entender que
francia conocido como el país de las
libertades pueda llegar a exigir la
vacuna contra el kobe 19
manejará muy buenas noches si es que
esta noche el disco sólo estamos
esperando animales a nivel personal yo
esta sonada tuve varias personas de mi
familia que fueron con kobe y además
estamos organizando una feria de arte
contemporáneo estamos atentos para saber
que va a decidir lo que vivimos es
justamente la prudencia la pedagogía del
gobierno es decir que ya lo sabíamos es
decir que el pase la apuesta que tiene
el gobierno en este momento de francia
es sobre el tema de la vacunación a
pesar que dijo que la vacunación no es
la panacea es por eso que pero sabemos
que esto está frenando las nuevas
variantes del cob y es por eso que el
enfoque muy fuerte va a ser justamente
hacer este papel
ahora cada tres meses y estamos hablando
vemos con israel- de la cuarta dosis
entonces va a ser exigió que los
franceses tenga su tercera dosis esto
está bien y mal percibido es decir que
como dije están tenemos una feria y nos
dimos cuenta que la gente está
utilizando falsos pases lo vemos
solamente con la fecha de nacimiento es
decir que todavía es complicado es
complicado yo estas noche estaba en el
metro alguien recomiendo otros genes que
fumando es decir que todavía falta
justamente pedagogía a la gente para ver
justamente este temor que es lo que está
provocando justamente el kobe en varios
países y en francia en particular pero
me pareció que justamente la pedagogía
de decir justamente reponer justamente
el resto xavier y otros estos y el temor
en el tema de las escuelas que
finalmente ya no vamos a esperar pero
por instante ellas estamos en stand by
sí señor ballan y hablemos del
descontento social porque en ocasiones
anteriores cuando el gobierno galo
endureció las medidas hubo protestas
ciudadanas cada fin de semana incluso
durante más de dos meses como pueden
reaccionar ahora los habitantes del país
ante este endurecimiento
bueno esto estamos mirando un poquito
escucha un poquito los políticos no hay
que olvidar que estamos a cuatro meses
de elecciones entonces es un momento
oportuno lo que dejo es decir que dejó
que nos asombremos es decir las en los
encuentros de personas para justamente
los partidos políticos va a ser
permitidos es decir que el nivel de
manifestación vamos a ver mañana pero la
medida de esta noche era una media soft
es decir que el pasto vaginal de
vacunación ya sabíamos que iba a entrar
lo confirmó entonces un instante ya no
hay ninguna medida que nos sorprendió de
dejar hacer fiestas para el primero de
enero no va a ser toque de queda creo
que muchas franceses en este momento
estamos en periodo vacacional estamos en
periodo festivos de amistad y de familia
o sea que por instante yo creo que las
cosas va a estar calmado vamos a ver el
5 cuando tiene que volver a abrir qué va
a pasar habrá que va a pasar a este
momento pero yo creo que de aquí al 5
estamos tranquilos bueno señor bola
nosotros estaremos atentos a que a qué
pasa de aquí al 5 por ahora nos
despedimos de usted y le agradezco este
panorama que nos da y ahora cambiamos de
noticia porque los legisladores
venezolanos de oposición extendieron por
un año lo que con como la presidencia
interina de juan guaidó la asamblea
nacional votó la propuesta en una web
conferencia de este lunes y así respaldó
la autoproclamación que hizo why do en
enero de 2019 sin embargo esta es una
figura cada vez más resquebrajada es que
el partido opositor 20 venezuela que
lidera maría corina machado afirmó que
la ruta de un gobierno interino ya se
agotó conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal daniela zambrano desde
caracas daniela bienvenida de nuevo a
france 24 y explíquenos qué significa la
extensión del gobierno interino de juan
guaidó
es un momento crucial para la oposición
venezolana que se continúe o no con esta
figura del gobierno interino puesto que
países como eeuu respaldan a juan guaidó
en la presidencia encargada pero si
dentro de la asamblea nacional esto no
se aprueba pues quedaría ya cerrada esta
figura de juan guaidó como presidente de
la asamblea nacional y de la presidencia
encargada de venezuela sin embargo vale
la pena destacar que este el proyecto
que fue aprobado hoy en sesión
extraordinaria de la asamblea nacional
fue aprobado con algunas restricciones
de ese gobierno interino y es que se le
requería atribuciones a la presidencia
encargada como por ejemplo designar a
juntas directivas e instituciones tanto
en venezuela como en el exterior también
la constitución de fondos de
financiamiento por ejemplo para
respaldar los activos de venezuela en el
exterior y esto fue rechazado por
diputados de la asamblea nacional que
respaldan que se continúe con juan
guaidó al frente de la presidencia y
encargada de venezuela espero que no se
le quiten atribuciones pues aseguran
esto viola la constitución ya otros
partidos opositores y otros dirigentes
se han pronunciado como fue julio hace
algunas semanas quien era canciller de
juan guaidó y decía que esta figura del
gobierno interino se debe acabar y hay
que continuar con nuevas rutas y también
como lo decías la dirigente opositora
maría corina machado también opinó igual
sin embargo esto fue la primera
discusión la segunda será el próximo 30
de diciembre pues recordemos el periodo
de la asamblea nacional vence el 5 de
enero del 2022 gracias daniela por esta
información el presidente de polonia
andrzej duda de todo un proyecto de ley
de medios de comunicación que afectaba a
la empresa estadounidense discovery
aunque su propio partido ley y justicia
impulsó el borrador en el parlamento
alegando que los extranjeros tenían
mucho poder en los medios de
comunicación hoy el mandatario lo hundió
él explicó que dañaba la imagen del país
como un lugar apto para hacer negocios y
es que la norma hubiera obligado a
discovery a ceder su participación en la
cadena de televisión polaca tvn24 que es
la mayor inversión estadounidense en
polonia
y sudáfrica comienza este lunes una
semana de homenajes al fallecido
arzobispo emérito de ciudad del cabo
desmond tutu premio nobel de paz y líder
de la lucha contra el apartheid los
homenajes acabarán el sábado primero de
enero con el funeral en la catedral de
san jorge' en ciudad del cabo
diez minutos diarios de redoble de
campanas es el homenaje que la catedral
de san jorge' de ciudad del cabo- hará a
desmond tutu desde este lunes hasta el
próximo sábado 1 de enero en esa fecha
la conocida como catedral del pueblo
durante su mandato como arzobispo
acogerá el funeral del que fuera premio
nobel de la paz
a las 10 de la mañana del sábado primero
de enero el funeral se realizará aquí y
también es aquí donde sus cenizas serán
enterradas desde el arzobispado y la
propia fundación de tutu advirtieron que
la asistencia será limitada debido a la
contingencia sanitaria sin embargo
iglesias y organismos oficiales de todo
el país serán habilitados para
homenajear a la voz de los sin voz como
lo nombró este lunes el presidente del
país a su llegada a la ciudad del cabo
white
el bin laden es poder
fue valiente fue franco y nos encantó
por eso porque era la voz de los sin voz
fue la única persona que hizo campaña
por la justicia por las personas que
viven con vih por ayuda a la comunidad
lgtb más y por las personas abatidas y
oprimidas community
ya que usted y por sus ideales lo
enfrentaron en varias ocasiones con el
poder eclesiástico son precisamente los
miembros de esos colectivos oprimidos
quienes honran su recuerdo con numerosos
homenajes
no importa quién seas no importa tu
sexualidad horas a lo que sea que haya
en tu cuenta bancaria realmente promovió
la idea del amor y la aceptación a cada
persona y esa es realmente una de las
lecciones que creo deberíamos llevar con
nosotros de color morado se homenajea a
quien barack obama recordó como la
brújula moral de sudáfrica morado es
también el color escogido por el
ayuntamiento de ciudad del cabo para
venerar a su arzobispo más universal
llegamos al final de esta emisión
informativa pero ustedes sigan con
nosotros para más información y vean más
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]